[Music]
how is it working during this pregnancy
if anything I'm like oh my gosh our
people even gonna want to watch me dance
around with this baby and spotted me but
I have more energy pregnant than I do
not pregnant of course she does that's
the Chrissy way Chrissy Teigen alongside
lip sync battle host LL Cool J clearly
loving being pregnant again but the baby
talk didn't stop there Chrissy revealing
to me that nearly two-year-old daughter
Luna is definitely proving to be daddy's
little girl she's definitely jealous of
John and I she's so protective of John
and when we kissed she gets very she
like looks from no matter where she
wherever she is she's like you see her
little dark eyes to learn oh my god a
little scary Mimi I think the balance is
hard I mean you know you want to be able
to give one so much attention and shower
them with love and affection and but
then you have a little baby - and I
thought be rough to balance but I'm
excited to figure it out because
hopefully we won't stop the - so John
and Chrissy want even more babies after
their little one arrives sometime this
spring
now do you know if it's wherever you do
what you're not telling not yes secrets
I know I share everything that John's
like no let's have something for us so
yeah I guess I don't know oh I'll tell
you later well tonight all eyes will be
on the pregnant working mom is she and
LL Cool J go live with a special lip
sync battle Michael Jackson tribute to
help launch the Paramount Network
I'm like the biggest Michael Jackson fan
in the world I'm like I you know knew
Mike personally we hung out many times
is the Jackson family gonna be involved
do you think Michael would just
something like this the state is
absolutely involved the family support
see we know Neil Patrick Harris Hailee
Steinfeld Laverne Cox and taraji P
Henson will be performing she posted
this video of her rehearsal last night
now how did you pick the song did you
guys have to fight out for what you
wanted to do they gave me a list and I'm
I just knew what I wanted to do turns
out lots of stars were asked to take
part tonight but they said no some
people were just so terrified about the
idea of stepping into my shoes that they
were like no way we'll do any other
episode with this one
[Music]
you